quand j'ai parlé à l'organisateur pour
la première fois l'idée de faire ce toc
il m'a dit sylvain ton sujet c'est
l'entreprise libéré là je lui ai répondu
stéphane ça commence mal l'entreprise
libéré j'y crois pas et pourtant j'en ai
cofondé une
j'ai 32 ans je m'appelle sylvain je vis
au vietnam depuis neuf ans je suis né
dans les vosges
j'ai eu un parcours assez classique
backès classes prépas écoles
d'ingénieurs la remise en cause avait
plutôt mal commencé en 2006 comme
beaucoup de jeunes ingénieurs
j'étais à la recherche d'un fameux stage
de fin d'études
grâce à ma formation d'autoproclamés
élites de la nation je décroche in
extremis un entretien dans une société
d'audit financier
mazars ils me diront que je ne convient
pas il avait bien raison
je retourne à mes recherches
le temps tourne c'est à ce moment que je
fais la rencontre qui va changer ma vie
ça te dit venir au vietnam
je ne connais rien du vietnam je n'ai
jamais mis les pieds en asie cela dit je
sais me servir de baguette
j'accepte trois semaines plus tard à 23
ans
j'atterris à saïgon c'est la première
étape de ma libération
tous les expats vous le diront rien de
tel que de regarder la france de loin
pour voir ce qui cloche
et puis passer son temps à l'observer en
vivant dans le pays le plus optimiste du
monde le vietnam
ça doit aider aussi alors au début ça
s'arrête à des clichés
oui on est on est quand même des sacrés
râleurs nous les français et puis petit
à petit on affine son jugement
je réalise aussi la chance que j'ai j'ai
mis un pied en dehors de la boîte
côté boulot
j'arrive dans une structure en éclosion
nous sommes trois tout est à faire
comment ça marche une entreprise
j'apprendrai tout grâce à deux alliés de
taille les livres et l'expérience
alors il faut être honnête au début on
réinvente pas la roue
on s'attache à ce qui marche enfin ce
qui marche
je lis les classiques tous les gros mots
du monde de l'entreprise y passe budget
reporting évaluation performance ma vie
c'est des voyages d'affaires des clients
exigeants des semaines de 60 heures ça
durera six ans est ce que je vis au
quotidien je les observe aussi dans mon
entourage proche
mes amis travaillent tous dans des
grosses boîtes ils ont tous un manager
et pour la plupart c'est un gros con au
fond de moi un côté rebelle se réveille
les questions qui me taraude
c'est est ce que ça marche vraiment est
ce qu'on peut pas faire autrement
à quoi ça sert un manager dans mon
esprit deux visions s'affrontent d'un
côté je porte un masque je fais semblant
comme ces costume mal taillé que je mets
pour allécher les clients de l'autre
j'ai envie d'être moi même de dire ce
que je pense un matin lors d'un voyage
d'affaires en france j'ouvre les yeux il
est 10h45
j'ai raté le réveil grosse journée du
difficile travail jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin problème ce matin là j'ai un
meeting clients à 11 heures
quelle excuse je vais bien pouvoir
trouver je me rappelle alors dès
dimanche soir passé devant la télé
devant ça cartoon où je réalisais que
j'avais complètement oublié le test de
maths du lendemain si lundi matin où
j'allais à l'école la peur au ventre
sachant la tôle qui m'attendait j'arrive
au meeting
je m'assois je me lance j'ai raté le
réveil silence gêné raté la veille ce
n'est pas dans le manuel utilisateur de
l'entreprise je regarde autour de moi
ces gens qui me jugent ont des vies et
parfois bien plus dur que la mienne ils
ont des enfants qui pleurent jusqu'à 3
heures du matin ils ont des engueulades
de couple pendant la pause déjeuner drr
qui partent en retard oui mais voilà
donc dans beaucoup d'entreprises avoir
une vie c'est interdit j'ai raté deux
réveils
cette fois ce sera la deuxième étape de
ma libération je décide alors que ma vie
et mon travail ne feront plus qu'un
pas un équilibre non une fusion à
commencer par les vêtements alors je
vais travailler en tongs et en t-shirt
le lundi matin on nous viennent mes
clients deviennent mes amis et vice
versa facebook remplace linkedin je ne
fais plus des voyages d'affaires pour
deux jours non je pars en voyage à
singapour à tokyo mes voyages s'allonge
jeu j'en profite pour me mettre à la
photo je ne fais plus des meetings je
rencontre des gens et pire je
m'intéresse à eux puis au hasard d'une
conversation dans un bas à paris un ami
me pose la question qui va me guider
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais tu es sûr qu'on
peut le souhaiter à tout le monde
ce mode de vie la réponse me paraît
évidente
et pourtant cette question revient si
souvent qu'elle en devient légitime
même pour moi je retourne une nouvelle
fois au vietnam
nous sommes maintenant une grosse
société de 300 personnes par chance on
est déjà plusieurs avaient fait ce
cheminement avoir mis les deux pieds en
dehors de la boîte
c'est décidé si nous voulons prouver que
c'est possible que oui on peut souhaiter
ce mode de vie à tout le monde
remettons l'humain au coeur de notre
entreprise
libérons là mais comment on libère une
entreprise non pas avec des manuels
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de manuels pour
faire ça alors on avance à tâtons
on teste on it erp et on fait des
erreurs
beaucoup d'erreurs comme ce jour on a eu
la brillante idée de dire fini les
managers sur le papier ça avait l'air
d'un vrai plan oui mais voilà le
problème c'est que les managers c'est
pas seulement un symbole devenir manager
c'est une évolution de carrière c'est un
statut social
c'est la promesse d'un gros salaire les
managers ils sont censés aussi
représentée ce leadership dont on a tous
besoin sur les salaires aussi on pouvait
pas faire comme tout le monde
alors on a dit chacun va décider de son
salaire je me souviens encore de ce jour
où une équipe de dix personnes a décidé
de prendre 50 % en augmentation alors on
a fait la gueule on s'attendait pas à ça
d'un côté si si un cofondateur refuser
ces augmentations
c'était c'était probablement la fin de
l'histoire finit l'autonomie de l'autre
si ça passe et c'était c'était
probablement l'escaladent des salaires
est probablement la fin de l' aventure
eh bien devinez quoi
ça n'est pas passé parce que chacun
pouvait prendre 50% d'augmentation oui
mais en le disant à tout le monde en
toute transparence
et quand tout le monde l'a su et bien
une personne a levé la main et a posé
une question plutôt sympa mais tu
demandes 50 % d'augmentation
c'est cool tu pourrais nous expliquer
comment ça va faire avancer notre
mission et puis une deuxième personne a
levé la main et une troisième des
questions moins sympa dis donc tu es sûr
que tu les mérites c'est 50%
l'équipe avait des comptes à rendre
mais pas aux mâts par ferme manager pas
au chef à leurs collègues et chaque
personne s'est retrouvée en face de ses
responsabilités bien c'est grâce à ces
expérimentations à ses erreurs que nous
avons commencé à comprendre les clés
d'une entreprise libérer une entreprise
libéré c'est d'abord des humains
rassemblés autour d'une cause on crois
aux mêmes choses on a la même mission et
les mêmes valeurs
travaillons ensemble la mission c'est ça
le nouvel actionnaire on travaille à son
service et toutes les décisions même les
augmentations de salaire sont prises en
la gardant en tête
ceci avec la mission qu'on choisit nos
clients par exemple ou qu'on décide des
nouveaux services a lancé à partir de là
on a une mission
on sait où on va mais comment on
s'organise on a vu qu'on avait tous
besoin de leadership
alors on est revenu à une définition à
une définition du leadership qui nous
plaisait bien
c'est quoi un leader bien un leader
c'est quelqu'un que les gens décident de
suivre
alors on a simplement proposé à chacun
de dire qu'il suivait et ça a donné ça
finit la pyramide
chacun choisit le leader varie en
fonction des projets et des collègues
les gens sont liés par des engagements
les uns envers les autres des relations
de menteur et part de la confiance par
défaut d'une hiérarchie pouvoir on passe
à une structure d' influence d'ailleurs
on n'a rien inventé
au lieu de relations fixé par une
pyramide on a simplement révélé des
relations naturelles
à ce moment-là l'admission on sait où on
va on sait comment on s'organise
mais comment on avance
eh bien on travaille dont on veut quand
on veut
sur les sur les sujets qu'on choisit on
s'auto gère et on raconte régulièrement
ce qu'on fait raconté régulièrement ce
qu'on fait si important ça permet de
créer de la confiance et ça permet aussi
de se synchroniser à nice a décidé de
travailler chez elle elle informe ses
collègues
et comme on se fait confiance elle se
permet même une petite blague cette
expérience elle est tirée de google+
google+ c'est notre outil transparence
cette transparence qui a permis la
régulation des salaires ou qui permet de
se synchroniser mais on a découvert une
utilisation encore plus intéressante
on y partage nos doutes nos soucis du
quotidien
c'est là où moi je par exemple moi par
exemple je peux dire désolé les gars
j'ai raté le réveil oui ça arrive encore
on y partage aussi nos joies nos succès
et nos photos de chats vous imaginez
vous envoyer une photo de chat par mail
à votre seo et bien grâce à google + on
a révélé une forme d'intelligence qui
est encore assez peu utilisé en
entreprise
l'intelligence émotionnelle on raconte
pas seulement ce qu'on fait on dit
comment on sent ce qu'on aime
chaque personne peut montrer de la
sympathie de l'empathie les uns envers
les autres et chaque personne peut
suivre ses sentiments et devenir un
capteur de l'humeur de l'entreprise
chaque personne peut enfin commencer à
retirer son masque et à devenir lui-même
pas ses utilisations particulières
libéré google+ c'est devenu notre outil
humain notre réseau social ces quelques
clés nous ont permis de comprendre
comment fonctionne une entreprise libéré
et vous avez sûrement remarqué ses clés
c'est pas des process aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de l'entreprise libéré on
sur arte les articles fleurissent dans
les hebdomadaires de management les
débats s'accumulent et dans ses
reportages ses articles ses débats une
question revient sans cesse est ce que
ça marche
et bien c'est à cette entreprise libéré
là que je ne crois pas celle qu on
vulgarise qu'on transforme en clichés en
process en titre vendeur la fin des
managers par exemple celle qu'on juge
uniquement suivant ses bénéfices et sa
croissance
la libération d'une entreprise c'est pas
un énième process de management qui va
miraculeusement tout changer alors oui
pour qu'elle se passe il faut qu'elle
soit décidé par le management
c'est d'ailleurs la dernière décision
stratégique comprend évidemment il
suffit pas de la décréter pour qu'elle
se passe c'est plus qu'une décision sa
demande d'une motivation intime de la
part d'un fondateur c'est accepter de
montrer de la fragilité c'est être
capable de dire j'ai fait une erreur
c'est aussi c'est aussi accepter de
prendre de la distance avec les
bénéfices la croissance ou le taux de
départ volontaire parce qu'une démission
eh bien ça peut être une bonne nouvelle
si ça permet d'initier une libération
individuel si la personne qui s'en va
décide de poursuivre notre mission par
d'autres moyens
un conflit interne c'est une opportunité
pour chacun de partager ses doutes et
d'avancer vers plus d'intégrité libérer
une entreprise sa demande à chacun des
individus de l'entreprise de se libérer
d'habitude prises et a prise de mettre
les sentiments le ressenti la
responsabilité individuelle et
collective sur le devant de la scène
alors là vous allez me dire mais moi
j'ai pas envie de ça et pourtant je peux
pas m'empêcher de vous le souhaitez
l'entreprise à laquelle je crois c'est
une ans c'est une entreprise vers nous
invite aux individus de s'affranchir
s'affranchir d'un certain mode
d'organisation et de relation et par ce
biais ça permet une certaine forme de
libération
alors aujourd'hui l'entreprise libéré
c'est encore assez marginal c'est trop
marginale à mon goût mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses à apprendre de
cette expérimentation grandeur nature
que nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux
à mener et quel que soit le service le
département finalement quelle que soit
l'échelle on peut expérimenter et ouvrir
la porte d'une entreprise où chacun
chaque jour peut décider d'être plus
sage plus libre et plus heureux merci